the two tankers that came under attack
in the Gulf of Oman with a Norwegian
owned but Marshall Islands flagged
frontal tear and the Japanese owned but
Panama flagged
kakuka courageous now u.s. naval forces
in the region said that they received
two separate distress calls one at 12
minutes past 6:00 and morning that's
local time and another at 7:00 a.m. so
shortly afterwards the US Navy guided
missile destroyer the USS Bainbridge
responded to those calls now the US Navy
presence in the region is aimed
primarily warding off any Iranian
closure of the Strait of Hormuz a key
maritime choke point the Straits are one
of the world's most important stretches
of water with one-fifth of the world's
oil passing through that waterway which
at its narrowest it's just 21 miles wide
and that includes crude oil and
liquefied natural gas from energy rich
countries in the Gulf region including
Iran Iraq Kuwait Saudi Arabia Qatar and
the United Arab Emirates conflict in the
Straits has the potential to create
shock waves across the world and that
could drive up the price of crude
today's attack alone caused oil prices
to surge by 4 percent during the 1980s
in the iran-iraq war the so called
tanker war Kuwait's oil tankers were
reflagged under a US flag so that oil
could be transported safely through the
Straits and more recently Iran's
president Hassan rouhani threatened to
close the Straits following the Trump
administration decision to leave the
Iranian nuclear deal